[Music]
well questions are flowing in but i had
received this question from brother
jonathan david archie um who whom you
know very well he acts when jesus was on
the cross and said my god my god why has
thou forsaken me in matthew chapter 27
verse 46
did god turn his face from the son or
did the father really forsake jesus but
jesus can't lie when jesus said why has
thou forsaken me is because the father
had forsaken him in the sense that he
turned away because all the sins of the
world were christ remember isaiah 59 1-2
your iniquities have hid his face from
you and your sins that he will not hear
you you say god doesn't look upon sin
all the sin was on christ
in galatians 3 13 christ said christ is
christ hath redeemed us from the curse
of the law being made a curse for us
well who made him a curse for us the
father so the father had to turn away he
did not leave the cross in the darkness
he was there but he turned away there
was a separation between the two
the father and the son which had never
occurred before
never occurred before and it really hurt
the godhead that that occurred the
father said it will never happen again
it's like taking a piece of material and
then you tear it that's what happened
when christ said why has now forsaken me
and it hurt the father deeply it hurt
the sun it hurt the spirit and the
father said it will never never happen
again so yes the father turned away and
christ was by himself
in that sense but the father was in the
darkness but he had to turn away and so
the christ for a while lost
the comfort of the presence of the
father's face
he withdrew his beams of love from the
sun and favor he withdrew them and the
angels were shocked when they saw that
wow
that happened they would have a
different look at sin altogether the
father withdrew his beams of faith and
love from the sun on that cross that's
why he cried out he couldn't take it
why his dial he took a lot of suffering
but he couldn't take that he cried out
while forsaking me
and the father forsook him so he
wouldn't have to forsake you and me
wow
i tell you the poignancy of the cross
and what jesus took on our behalf even
separation from the father
so that we could be saved
so why spurn salvation it is full and
free through jesus
let me also say this god was in christ
reconciling the world unto himself so in
a certain sense god experienced what
christ experienced
because god gave himself in christ
now he's a tremendous god gave himself
in christ he he worked out a way to give
himself for the race he gave himself in
christ the bible says god was in christ
reconciling the world reconciliation
requires death romans 5 verse 10 somehow
now i'm not saying the father died but
he experienced what jesus experienced
because christ experienced death in the
garden of gethsemane without physically
dying let me say that again
hebrews 2 verse 9 says he tasted death
for every man to taste death you have to
be alive to taste it christ experienced
death while you were still alive no one
else has had that the father suffered
with the son in a real sense the father
experienced what christ experienced now
christ in his physical condition
actually died the father is not physical
so he couldn't die but he experienced
what jesus experienced
and since hebrews chapter 9 verse 14
says christ offered himself through the
eternal spirit the spirit suffered and
the angels suffered all of heaven
suffered
to save you
to save one human being all the godhead
and all the angels went through that
suffering
salvation is expensive
but free
wow wow praise god praise god
thank you so much for those responses
elder skeet we greatly appreciate your
time
[Music]